you're watching film courage yeah
hi We're King is a think I'm julica and
I'm just cooking and we just got
finished filming our filming taping film
courage with David Brad and Karen warden
and we had some people don't need to
tilt what we were doing it Andrew black
Marcela selbach who is movie angel on
the Twitter and Michele Simmons Mojave
66 on Twitter Thank You 4466 4466 is
it's okay sorry about that also we had
some people up their pledges sherry
candler Jake stettler and Paul Barrett
or Mayor Paul Barrett some of you may
know him until the town thank you so
much very nice well that was exciting to
have happened while we were on the air
and I don't think we covered this one
question which I think a lot of people
are curious about it maybe you're
curious yourselves what's next for the
two of you you know you have tilt coming
up you're raising the money but even
beyond tilt what do you envision for
yourselves this is something we think
about quite a bit where are we going
from here and we're definitely going to
keep writing um and ideally we have some
scripts and not Julie will probably talk
about one of them in just a minute
that's sort of in the treatment stage
and then we'd like to do what we've done
with Phil Holbrook again we would love
to team up with other independent
filmmakers to go through this process
again that's something we'd like to do
and our next immediate project is
adapting a naughty memoir by an amazing
writer named Kevin Keck I like to call
him my cousin he may or may not be
you'll never know um and he's written a
couple of memoirs out of his wrecks and
are you there god it's me kevin as well
as some poetry that's really great but
he said if we wanted to give a shot at
adapting it into a movie that we could
do it so we jumped at the chance so
that's what we're going to be doing next
so curious when you talk about plans for
the future I mean are you the types that
will plan out five year goals 10 year
goals and and are very specific in
writing down you want to happen or you
more free-flowing and ideas just kind of
come to you more spontaneously i would
say that we we definitely are planners
we probably don't we don't have
something like in 10 years is exactly
where i want to be but in terms of
projects but we do know how we want to
live and work like we know one of my big
things is it's not about what you want
to be it's about how do you want to
spend your time and we know exactly how
we want to spend our time we want to
spend our time being creative together
and we want to do that in a way that is
sustaining so that we can live not
extravagantly just comfortably be
creative together make films write books
like stories travel travel and that
would be our ideal and I think that in
terms of a 10-year goal i think that
would that's where I hope to be in 10
years and I'd like to add I think it's I
like having that goal and not saying you
know we want to make this many movies
you know before 2015 or do this exact
thing because you know we had no idea a
couple years ago that this is what we
would be doing now we didn't know we
know you guys be on the show be making
them so with bill and I like being a
little more free-flowing because you
never know where things are going to
take you so I'm excited to see what
happens next